- Hey, man, "Key & Peele," man.
Hey, you know what, man?
Fuck y'all!
- Stupid.
- Straight up, man.
We're doing this
a long-ass time now.
Y'all ain't done shit.
And you know what,
it's on you now, dawg.
And you know why?
I'ma tell you right now.
Because we watched
this week's episode,
didn't even like that shit.
You know what, fuck it.
I'm gonna show
the goddamn scene anyway.
I want everybody watching
this video right now
to see how stupid
and fucked up your scene is.
So show the goddamn clip.
[slow footsteps]
- Goo gah gah...
- Oh.
Hey, there, Forrest.
- Goo-goo, gah-gah.
I want...I want milk.
- You want me to get you
your bottle, buddy?
- I want milk.
- Okay.
- Now, how y'all gonna
fuck up a black Hobbit scene?
- Stupid, man.
- Ridiculous, man.
And everything was taking place
at regular time.
They should be
in a Hobbit village.
- Throw some celebrity
Hobbits in there.
- That's what they should do,
is put a celebrity Hobbit
up in there, man,
to play the black Hobbit, man.
- Webster...
- Yeah, Webster, man.
Ha, that's my jam.
Webster would have
been my shit.
- Dinkle, Dinkle.
- Oh, shit, Peter Dinkle
from "Game of Thrones."
Why didn't you all get
that nigga to be in your shit?
That should have been
the funniest scene this season.
Y'all fucked it right on up.
- Also got a big dick,
though.
- [laughing]
And then he should have had
hair on his feet
and a big old hairy dick.
How you gonna have a midget
without a big dick?
- [snickering]
- See?
- That's just funny, dawg.
That's just universal.
That's universal.
I don't know how you
drop the ball on that one.
- The midget got to have
a big dick, man.
He should have slapped
the babysitter in his face.
He should have said, "Nice
babysitter, nice babysitter."
both: Blip!
And slapped him in the dick.
And the babysitter went like...
[makes fart noise]
"Oh, man, this little
baby midget made me fart."
[laughter]
- That's just--
nigga, that's just--
Man, you stupid.
You being stupid
right now.
- But you know what?
Hey, you know what,
fuck you, though.
Fuck you, though.
You know, we laughing
and everything,
but it ain't at you, man.
We laugh at our own shit,
'cause our shit is gold.
So y'all better watch out,
'cause from now on it's gonna be
"Huggins & Taylor," all right?
That's the new show.
Fuck "Keele & P,"
'cause we done
with you now, man.
We done.
We was trying to help you out.
- Yep.
- But now we're gonna
take our shit on the road.
- Yep.
- And fuck your shit up.
Lot of stuff
missing in your show.
Y'all don't have
enough shit in your show.
The whole goddamn season,
one time,
it's the only time
you did it, man,
where that dude shit himself
when they was about to do
that drive-by on that one dude.
That was my shit.
That's the funniest thing
they did all season, man.
- That's my shit right there.
- What's wrong with y'all, man?
How come you only do that
one time?
Man, those dudes should have
been in every show.
Put shit-pants gangsters
in the show.
That's what I call the scene,
"shit-pants gangsters."
- Make that the whole show,
nigga.
- That's what they should call--
that's what their names
should be, too.
They should call 'em
Shit-pants
and--and--and Fart-drawers.
That would be
those niggas' names.
"My name is fart-drawers.
This is my partner,
Shit-pants."
- Hold up.
- [laughing]
- I'm gonna write
that shit down.
- You gonna write that down?
You got a pencil, man?
- Write that shit down.
- Hold up, I got a piece
of paper right here, man.
Shit-pants and Fart-drawers.
And I wish you niggas
would try and steal that shit.
Please try and steal it.
Hey, nigga, put an "R"
with a circle around it.
- Nigga, hold up
a second, now.
- Put an "R" with a circle
around it.
- Hold up one second.
All right.
- Shit-pants.
- All right, start
from the--Shit-pants...
- And then his partner
name is--
- Hold up, nigga,
I'm trying to write something.
And...
- Fart-drawers.
- That's on the wall.
- Take that, niggas.
- Bitch.